not so much swallow it swallow it I did
cool hey what's going on everybody for
firstly fees I'm Sean Evans coming at
you from Jimmy's 43 in the East Village
where I'm joined by my good friend
comedian Bert Kreischer I'm so blown
away what a good host you are thank you
harder the host looking for seven years
ago I could not do that reader one take
no problem and I'll just keep it going
you know Miss Bertha machine I know him
as the manchild and he's also perhaps
most importantly the life of the party
that has its consequences like now so
naturally what we're going to be doing
is testing out some of the most sworn by
hangover cures around the globe and then
we're just going to give it a thumbs up
or thumbs down based on whether or not
we think would bring us back to life how
much did you drink last night and how do
you feel this morning I started drinking
at 7 a.m. Sunday morning at the airport
in Orlando drank on the plane took him
nap middle with Nate bargatze started
drinking again it or drank until serene
and that brings us to right here we have
a shot of whiskey region can whiskey
last night yes I was all right well then
that's the thing like it'll just keep it
going
that was good
first up out of Eastern Europe we have
pickle juice there's that famous
Philadelphia Eagles urban legend about
the pickle juice game where the team
they drink pickle juice before playing
109 degree Fahrenheit heat to win the
game yeah the classic pickle juice thing
oh really bloated [ __ ] the whole thing I
mean I think we should like haters bro
it was a like we just killed it yeah I
just plant it slam it Jesus Bert oh you
onto something here it's kind of like a
Bloody Mary because we've got that
saltiness pickles make you feel like
you're not cheating right it feels like
a little bit uh
like we're having a little green juice
yeah is pickle juice thumbs up hangover
cures the thumbs-down hangover cure
where are you on how it helps you coach
and that it's getting bloated thumbs up
thumbs up for me to unload it so I could
have another one and a shot
is anyone here that up next we have
menudo out of Mexico oh yeah I didn't
know it was a food and apparently a very
interchangeable boyband Ricky Martin
Martin was part of the menudo I think so
Ricky Martin was it can somebody
fact-check that
so I mentioned that there is a certain
fear factor quality to today's video and
you can see this sort of honeycomb
situation that I just pulled out of the
bra got the two so what that is that's
trite tripe is the stomach lining of a
cow I mean discount diverticulitis
what does it look like yeah it's all
about the seasoning I think oh I love
this the dish is made with red chili
pepper it's supposed to stimulate the
senses and clear the head
we need a phenomenal let's take this to
a professional level I drink a lot got
hungover a lot I'm in airports a lot
yeah if I was at an airport and I saw
new toast and I would be in there in a
sec this is exactly I'm looking for in
the morning no time for a breakfast
burrito
no one's only her oatmeal normally what
I love and I hope I want menudo you're
into it I love it I'm really into this
I'm really into this by the way two
massive bugs up - I - likewise and
giving it a thumbs up you know it's like
on a raw ingredient level little it's a
lot to take in you know and you're like
I don't know how this is all going to
work for some reason it comes out
perfectly
very paleo bro next up out of Germany we
have Rollmops not what this is is a
pickle to hearing the fish it's rolled
up around a savory filling and then
finally the reason it's a hangover cure
is the herring is loaded with fatty
acids that prevent heart disease and
keep the brain functioning that's all
the hangover cure ingredients of doctor
Kadare what's up songs getting healthy
[Music]
all right another whodunit not so much
wallet swallow that I did cool not
loving it what I had in Germany I'm
being sheep of God you think that's
right up my alley I love that kind of
stuff but that is [ __ ] disgusting
it was so fishy I felt like so fishy
grizzly bear that had just caught a fish
out of the creek and then just bit into
it oh my god it dripped on my hand I
can't believe I didn't like that I am
I'm being serious when I says I'm a
lover of life I like everything
I really didn't enjoy that I really did
not enjoy that on a hangover cure level
what are you doing giving it a thumbs up
some thumbs up because I automatically
go oh life so much better I don't have
that in my life I took a bite and spit
it out I don't want that I know what I
don't want we can get through this day
so in that way it's probably the best
hangover cure that we're going to have
today can you imagine growing up where
this is something that they would make
good luck making from the school that
you're like [ __ ] pickled herring and
onions all right so these are Prairie
oysters time-honored in the United
States do you have any experience with
these yes I know that they've done with
brandy also I hate brandy a little
brandy in mind you don't have any brandy
in your I'll put it in if you're doing
this when I watch got Yeti well look
thank um she doesn't like eggs and it
always bothered you I love eggs I want
to experience him eat the meal with the
eggs so I'm not going to go JD this you
hear that guy you hear that guy
so this is a prairie oyster it consists
of Worchester sauce tomato juice vinegar
a hot water starter solid starter what's
the charge versus tire wordless toaster
sauces warchest I what the chat type
we're sorry we're Chang Wishart this is
a prairie oyster big in the USA it
consists of tomato juice vinegar hot
sauce salt ground black pepper and
little raw egg action the raw egg
because it's like a real oyster hence
the name first time ever this is
intimidating I've done it before I'm not
with brandy but I've done it before
get ready it's amazing the yolk really
just chasing it down so they're thinking
behind it is by introducing new toxins
to your body like capsaicin will put an
end to your body's processing of alcohol
that's the things like when you're when
you're a kid and you hit your finger
with a hammer and you then your dad hit
you in the arm is like now you're not
thinking about your finger it's the same
exact thing I'll give it a thumbs up
because it shouldn't sell as well as it
does you know what I mean like when
you've given given the ingredients given
what you'd have to put on a menu to sell
it it has zero going for it but in fact
it actually is kind of like a smooth
drink to throw down and does kind of
like bring you back to light bulb it was
enjoyable I got it I gotta be honest
with you all right Bert chronic hang
hands down no questions asked
menudo menudo is the best thing I've
ever put in my mouth I put a lot of
crazy stuff in my pal
menudo is phenomenal if you offered it
got to me at an airport in the morning
when I'm hungover at my worst
shaky sitting with Stanhope and the guy
says to get us Moodle I go you hopefully
not the band right
I mean the food maybe like cattle and
then he serves up menudo and then we
starting menudo all right you heard it
here first world Bert Kreischer the life
of the party he loves menudo check out
Bert on the machine oh look how big my
head is whoa I think here's what I'll
say